one two three  I Gotta Give My Girl a present she got  one for me she wrapped it up real pretty  [Music]  I go way too late  every Year's the same thing I  procrastinate it's almost Christmas  [Music]  maybe find the right perfume  I'm open to suggestions but they better  get here soon  he goes shopping early  I go way too late  same thing I procrastinate it's almost  Christmas  and I'm the last one in the store it's  almost Christmas  before it's almost Christmas  [Music]  did I hear smell the rain it's almost  Christmas  I haven't bought a thing  everything is closing down  not one president has that found  now they're locking up the door  I don't know what I'm shopping for  it's almost Christmas  and I'm the last one in the store almost  Chris  I can't do this anymore it's almost  Christmas  and  [Music]  a heaven got a thing  it's almost Christmas  [Applause]  [Music]  it's almost Christmas  [Applause]